[Musique]
merci brossa d'être avec nous pendant
cette première demi-heure vous êtes élu
de Paris membre du groupe communiste
porte-parole d'ailleurs du Parti
communiste on va revenir sur plusieurs
questions qui vous concerne et sur
lesqueles vous travaillez la question du
logement et puis cette votation sur les
SUV hier à Paris mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est toujours cette crise
agricole est-ce que avec les mesures
qu'il a annoncé vendredi vous diriez que
Gabriel Atal a réussi à éteindre
l'incendie pas du tout ou alors en tout
cas de manière extrêmement provisoire
mais les questions qui étaient posées
par les agriculteurs depuis plusieurs
semaines maintenant plusieurs mois en
réalité la question de savoir comment
ils peuvent vivre de leur travail cette
question là de mon point de vue elle
n'est pas réglée du tout et ça n'est pas
parce que le gouvernement décide de
mettre sur pause le plan écofyo que les
agriculteurs peuvent dire que demain ils
pourront vivre de leur travail la
question des prix rémunérateurs la
question des traités de libre échange la
question la répartition des aides de la
politique agricole commune toutes ces
questions-là elles sont devant nous
d'ailleurs les les élections européennes
seront l'occasion d'en débattre mais de
ce point de vue-là le gouvernement n'a
strictement rien réglé alors sur sur les
traités de libre échange il y a un bras
de fer sur la question du mercosour sur
lequel la France est très opposée pour
vous ça suffit pas non ça ne suffit pas
d'abord parce que le gouvernement a
depuis des années maintenant ce
gouvernement Emmanuel Macron ses
ministres défendu bec et ongles tous les
traité de libre échange là en
l'occurrence à l'approche des élections
européennes et sous la pression de ce
mouvement il se réveille mais qu'est-ce
qui nous garantit que demain le traité
de libre échange avec les pays du
Mercosur ne reviendra pas et par
ailleurs je RA pense que c'est juste
électoraliste pendant les Européennes et
qu'après les européennes il y aura un
changement bien sûr qu'il y a derrière
des considérations parfaitement
électoralistes puisqu'il y a quelques
semaines quelques mois maintenant les
mêmes ont promu un traité de libre
échange avec la Nouvelle-Zélande qui
fait que nos étals de supermarché sont
envahis de moutons qui viennent de
Nouvelle-Zélande c'est-à-dire à à
plusieurs milliers de kilomètres de
notre pays de l'autre bout du monde et
au fond je pense que ce mouvement des
agriculteurs doit nous inviter à à nous
poser des questions profondes quel
modèle économique voulons-nous est-ce
que nous voulons continuer à importer
des produits que nous sommes capables de
faire par ailleurs nous-mêmes qui
viennent de l'autre bout du monde est-ce
que c'est un modèle qui est soutenable
est-ce que c'est un modèle qui est
favorable à l'agriculture il faut mettre
fin à tous les traités de libre échange
pour vous il faut de notre point de vue
d'autres modes de coopération que la
multiplication de ces traité de libre
échange qui font que nous sommes envahis
par des produits qui ne correspondent
pas à nos normes environnementales pas
davantage à nos normes sociales
d'ailleurs vu la manière dont ils sont
produits et donc oui bien sûr cette
question est devant nous est-ce qu'il y
a pas un risque pour nos exportations
qu'est-ce que vous dites par exemple aux
éleveurs de de porort qui eux exportent
jusqu'en Chine à des milliers de
kilomètres mais je pense que toutes ces
questions là il faut les poser et se
demander quel est le modèle économique
qui permet à la fois de défendre euh
notre agriculture nos productions de
manière plus générale et qui permet
aussi de protéger notre environnement
mais on ne peut pas faire comme si la
question climatique n'existait pas ce
sont de grandes questions c'est notre
avenir qui est en jeu et donc il faut
avoir le courage de les poser justement
sur la question climatique il y a eu
cette polémique sur la suspension du
plan écophyo hier Christophe Béchu s'est
voulu rassurant le ministre de la
transition écologique il dit que c'est
qu'une pause de 3 semaines jusqu'au
salon de l'agriculture le temps de
mettre en place de nouveaux indicateurs
mais que l'objectif de baisse de 50 %
des pesticides d'ici à 2030 demeure ça
vous a rassuré nous verrons bien et nous
verrons ce qui se dessinera d'ici le
salon de l'agriculture qui doit avoir
lieu dans quelques semaines maintenant
ce qui est sûr et et et en tout cas
c'est la position que nous défendons
c'est que l'environnement ne peut pas
être une variable d'ajustement puisque
c'est notre condition de de survie des
agriculteurs aussi d'ailleurs parce que
ce sont les premier touché c'est cette
question-là qui est posée et donc la
vraie question c'est pas de savoir si on
abaisse nos normes la vraie question
c'est qu'on ne peut pas accepter d'avoir
sur le territoire français des
importations de produits qui ne
correspondent en rien aux normes que
nous nous appliquons à nous-mêm parce
que évidemment que ça introduit une
concurrence déloyale qui indigne les
agriculteurs et qui nous indigne tous
parce que ça n'est pas le bon sens que
de faire cela et là-dessus il a pas fait
un premier pas Gabriel Attal quand il
interdit l'importation de fruits et
légumes traité avec un pesticide venant
de qui est interdit en France mais qui
est autorisé dans le reste de l'Union
européenne c'est pas un bon début c'est
un début c'est une prise de conscience
tardive une fois de plus après avoir
signé tous les traités de libre échange
de la terre en tout cas pour ce qui nous
concerne nous au parti communiste nous
avons toujours été cohérents puisque à
chaque fois que nous avons eu cette
occasion nous avons rejeté ces traités
de libre échange un dernier mot sur la
rémunération des agriculteurs et et le
gouvernement qui se sont très ferme avec
la grande distribution qui dit qu'il y
aura des sanctions des amendes pour ceux
qui ne respectent pas la loi égalim vous
saluez cette fermeté en tout cas je je
note quand même une forme de de poids de
mesure parce que des sanctions vis-à-vis
de la grande distribution le
gouvernement aurait pu les prendre il y
a très longtemps parce que ça fait
longtemps que ces professions
essortent nos agriculteurs et dans le
même temps vous avez les plus modestes
qui dans notre pays dès qu'ils ne font
pas exactement ce qu'on leur demande de
faire se retrouvent eux soumis à des
sanctions vous voyez bien le le le RSA
soumis à 15h de travail par semaine donc
mon sentiment c'est qu'il y a quand même
deux poids de mesure dans ce pays quand
vous êtes fort quand vous vous êtes
puissant vous avez toujours une marge de
négociation quand vous êtes faible vous
avez la sanction qui vous tombe dessus
tout de suite on va parler du logement
sujet que vous suivez beaucoup parmi les
thèmes abordés par Gabriel hata lors de
son discours de de politique générale il
a eu cette question le Premier ministre
qui a notamment promis un choc de
l'offre on va voir tout ça avec Alex
[Musique]
Poussard bonjour Alex bonjour Yan
bonjour Yan brossa bonjour et Alex dans
son discours de politique générale
Gabriel Attal a donc présenté ses
solution face à la crise du logement oui
alors d'abord un chiffre sur cette crise
du logement on fait en ce moment les 70
ans de l'appel de l'abbis pierre pour
les sansabris et bien en 2023 en France
il y a 300 il y avait 330000 personnes
sans domicile fixe 4,2 million de
personnes en situation de mallogement
2,4 millions de personnes en attente
d'un logement social selon le dernier
rapport de la Fondation abépierre alors
pour faire face à cette crise du
logement Gabriel Attal a rappelé à la
semaine dernière au sénateur les
engagements du gouvernement pour créer
ce qu'il appelle un choc d'offre
c'est-à-dire une relance de la
production de logement avec la promesse
de créer 30000 nouveaux logements en 3
ans en accélérant les procédures en
réquisitionnant les bâtiments en vide et
puis concernant le secteur du logement
social Gabriel Atal a fait des annonces
pour soutenir le secteur un nouveau prêt
de 2 milliards d'euros le pouvoir sera
donné au Mair dans l'attribution des
logements sociaux sur le territoire de
leur commune et il propose de réformer
la loi SRU qui on le rappelle cette loi
elle fixe l'objectif aux communes
urbaines de détenir d'ici à 2025 entre
20 % et 25 % de logements sociaux pour
leur territoire et Gabriel Atal il
souhaite assouplir cette loi en y
incluant et bien les logements
intermédiaires accessibles aux classes
moyennes on
l'écoute nous proposons que les
logements intermédiaires accessibles à
la classe moyenne soit désormais inclus
dans le calcul de la part de logement
social dans le cadre de la loi SRU
je veux le dire aussi clairement à ceux
qui s'inquiètent dans les communes
soumise à la loi nous maintiendrons
évidemment une exigence d'un nombre
minimal de logements très sociaux et
cette annonce elle inquiète
effectivement les acteurs du secteur du
logement et également certains maires
qui dénoncent et bien une mesure qui va
gonfler artificiellement les chiffres du
logement social en France en y incluant
les logements intermédiaires Yan brossa
quand même l'intention du Premier
ministre s bien c'est de rendre
davantage accessibles les logements
interméiaires aux classes moyennes ça
peut paraître louable ce qui prouve bien
que le nouveau Premier ministre ne
connaît strictement rien ni au logement
ni au logement social en particulier
puisque en l'occurrence le logement
social est accessible au classe moyenne
le logement social aujourd'hui au vu des
plafonds de ressources qui sont
pratiqués il est éligible pour 70 % des
Français 70 % des Français le logement
intermédiaire il s'adresse aux Français
qui gagne plus que ces 70 % là donc en
réalité il s'adresse aux classes
moyennees supérieur et donc la vraie
question ça n'est pas celle-là c'est
comment on relance la production de
logements sociaux c'est-à-dire l'exacte
inverse de ce que le gouvernement a fait
depuis 2017 puisqu'il ponctionne chaque
année plus d'un milliard d'euros dans la
caisse dans les caisses des bailleurs
socieux ce qui explique qu'aujourd'hui
le logement social est en panne si je
vous pique tout ce que vous avez dans
votre compte en banque forcément vous
avez du mal à faire des investissements
derrière c'est exactement ce qui se
produit aujourd'hui et donc le
gouvernement est en train en réalité de
tuer une deuxème fois à la baaipierre et
il est en train de démanteler la loi SRU
qui date de 2000 et qui permet 25 % de
logements sociaux dans chaque commune
donc ça pourrait avoir l'effet inverse
cette annonce finalement de ne pas
relancer la production de logements
sociaux mais bien sûr c'est une mesure
qui va tuer le logement social puisque
aujourd'hui vous aviez des maires qui
n'étaient pas au 25 % et l'État leur
disait le préfet leur disait il faut que
vous produisiez du logement social pour
atteindre le seuil des 25 %. demain ces
maires qu'est-ce qu'ils diront ils
diront bah au lieu produire du logement
social comme j'ai pas envie d'avoir trop
de gens modestes chez moi ou même des
petites classes moyennes et ben je vais
faire du logement intermédiaire donc en
réalité c'est une mesure contre le
logement social et contre la mixité
sociale parce que la loi SRU elle a été
conçue pour favoriser la mixité sociale
c'est-à-dire pour faire du logement
social là où il y en avait peu dans une
ville comme la mienne à Paris en 20 ans
depuis la la loi su nous sommes passés
de 13 % de logements sociaux à 25 % de
logements sociaux il y a plein d'autres
communes qui elles aussi et éta en
déficit et ont peu à peu rattraper leur
retard et ben il y a des tas de communes
qui ne rattraperont plus leur retard
puisqu'elles pourront faire du logement
intermédiaire au lieu de faire du
logement social Gabriel Attal souhaite
également donner le pouvoir au maires
dans l'attribution des premiers
logements sociaux sur le territoire de
leur commune c'est une bonne idée de il
y a déjà des des commissions de
peuplement qui existent
aujourd'hui oui lorsqu'il y a des
livraisons d'ensemble sociaux c'est une
réalité il a l'air de de découvrir
quelque chose qui existe déjà pour le
reste euh moi je le dis très clairement
le sujet c'est pas la question des
attributions de logements sociaux c'est
la question de la production de
logements sociaux parce que au train où
on va y aura plus rien à attribuer parce
que la réalité c'est que on produit de
moins en moins de logement social en
2016 on en produisait plus de 120000 par
an aujourd'hui on est autour de 80000
par an vous vous rendez compte ils sont
depuis 7 ans au pouvoir et ils ont en
réalité saccagé le logement social en
France et donc de ce point de vue-là
c'est très inquiétant on peut discuter
des attributions pendant des heures mais
s'il y a plus rien à attribuer la
discussion aura un intérêt limité alors
selon vous comment on fait pour relancer
cette production de logement on remet de
la la dépense publique dans le secteur
il s'agit pas de remettre de la dépense
publique dans le secteur il s'agit
d'abord d'arrêter de ponctionner les
bailleurs sociaux qu'on arrête de
prendre 1 milliard d'euros plus d'un
milliard d'euros 1 milliard 3 dans la
caisse des bailleurs sociaux qu'on leur
donne de l'air du point de vue du point
de vue financier c'est ça pour moi le le
le sujet si on a envie que nos bailleurs
sociaux fassent du logement neuf Renov
le parc existant ce qui est un enjeu
majeur au vu de l'envoler des prix de
l'énergie quand on rénove
énergétiquement un bâtiment ça fait des
charges qui baissent ça fait du pouvoir
d'achat en plus pour les locataires si
on veut qu'il puisse faire les deux bah
il faut leur donner les moyens de le
faire donc arrêter de leur piquer de
l'argent comme c'est le cas depuis 2017
maintenant et en même temps cette crise
du logement c'est une crise
multifctorielle il y a la hausse des
taux d'intérêt la hausse du prix du
foncier la baisse du rythme de la
construction est-ce que les les
communistes ont la solution à cette
crise complexe bah par exemple vous av
évoqué la question du du du prix du
foncier c'est une question qui avait
d'ailleurs été abordée dans le cadre du
CNR sur le logement celui qui avait été
organisé par par Olivier clin de laond
absolument il y avait des propositions
sur le foncier qui visaient à encadrer
le prix de foncier le gouvernement a
balayé cette proposition d'un revers de
main alors que c'est une question une
question absolument majeure et et qui de
mon point de vue doit être relancé ça
fait en tout cas partie des solutions
encadrer les prix de foncier parce que
aujourd'hui ce qui fait que le logement
est très cher c'est le foncier est
souvent très cher un dernier mot parce
que il y a est-ce que vous êtes inquiet
à Paris spécifiquement sur le logement
pendant les Jeux Olympiques évidemment
que il y a des motifs d'inquiétude
notamment parce que je vois je suis
alerté du fait que des propriétaires
décident de faire des congés pour vente
ou des des des congés pour reprise pour
pouvoir louer leur logement pendant la
période des giio donc ça fait des
locataires qui sont obligés de de partir
d'abandonner leur leur logement et pour
pouvoir le le le mettre a PIR le louer
pardon effectivement pour pouvoir le
louer sur Airbnb et encaisser beaucoup
d'argent effectivement c'est c'est très
inquiétant et d'ailleurs je me félicite
que la Ville de Paris ait fait le choix
de de de lancer une campagne
d'information en direction des
locataires pour leur faire connaître
leurs droits vous n'avez pas le droit de
vous débarrasser de votre locataire
comme vous voulez simplement parce que
vous voulez faire du fric pendant la
période des GI quand on est locataire on
a des droits vous allez agir au niveau
de législatif en tout cas nous allons
déposer au Conseil de Paris cette
semaine une proposition qui vise à
mettre en une trève olympique sur les
expulsions faire en sorte que on nit pas
d'expulsion pendant la période des gios
et et moi je Seris favorable à ce que
tout cela effectivement puisse déboucher
sur une loi faire en sorte que 2024 soit
une année blanche en matière d'expulsion
locative parce que je vois bien sur tout
le territoire ou uniquement par en tout
cas dans les zones tendues dans les
zones qui sont concernées par la
présence de touristes pendant les j
parce que je vois bien qu'un certain
nombre de de propriétaires malfaisants
font le choix de se débarrasser de leur
locataire pour faire de gros profits
pendant la période des j au détriment de
de ces locataires obligés de partir donc
vous déposez une proposition de loi dans
les jour je je le ferai il faut encore
que je termine le travail avec mes
collègues mais en tout cas oui oui je le
souhaite merci Alex à tout à l'heure
ouais à tout à l'heure on parlera de la
mise en pause annoncée par le
gouvernement du plan de réduction des
pesticides ce sera à suivre dans le club
on va voir l'actualité du côté de Paris
on retrouve jacqu paquet bonjour Jacques
merci d'être avec nous bjour un
rédacteur en chef du journal du Grand
Paris Jacques hier les parisiens étaient
appelés à se prononcer sur le triple du
stationnement des
SUV tout à fait le triplement du du
tarif donc
54,5 55 % des votants se sont prononcés
pour ce triplement de la des tarif ce
qui peut être considéré comme un un
succès seulement un petit problème c'est
que seulement 5,68 % des des inscrits se
sont
déplacés Yan brossa comment pensez-vous
qu'on que vous deviez agir pour essayer
de d'attirer davantage les Parisiens
vers cette démocratie participative dont
on peut reconnaître qu'elle a le mérite
de la pédagogie hein sur des sujets de
de société mais qui peineent à à
convaincre est-ce qu'il y avait pas là
un un un petit problème d'expression
puisque la campagne de publicité de
promotion a dit a demandé aux Parisiens
de se prononcer pour ou contre les SUV
alors qu'on a compris au fil du temps
qu'en fait il s'agiss c'est de de de
tripler le le tarif de stationnement
dans les rues des véhicules lourds qu'il
soit SUV ou ou ou ou
berline d'abord je pense qu'on peut pas
comparer un taux de participation d'une
élection une élection municipale ou une
élection présidentielle avec un
référendum sur une question bien précise
et et assez ponctuelle par ailleurs
l'organisation du vote n'est n'est pas
la même hein puisque dans la plupart des
arrondissements le mien notamment le 18e
il y avait un seul le bureau de vote qui
était en mairie du 18e si vous décidez
de vous aligner sur le mode
d'organisation d'une élection normale ça
aurait un coup faramineux mais quand
même moin 6 % c'est pas un échec et
certains ne se privveraient pas de nous
le reprocher mais euh non vous savez on
passe parfois des heures à commmenté des
sondages qui ont été réalisés sur 500 ou
sur 1000 personnes là en l'occurrence on
a quasiment 80000 parisiens qui sont
mobilisés pour ce vote et donc ça crée
une légitimité claire pour présenter une
libération au mois de mai sur le sujet
qui pourra tripler le prix des SUV et et
de ce point de vue moi je me félicite de
cet exercice
démocratique et par ailleurs le le le
résultat est intéressant ça montre qu'il
y a une majorité à Paris pour considérer
que la priorité à l'environnement à la
réduction de la place des voitures
polluantes cette majorité elle est là
elle est claire et d'ailleurs elle fait
suite à à à à à des positions que les
Parisiens ont toujours défendu sur la
piétonisation des voies sur berge sur le
développement des pistes cyclables les
Parisiens sont cohérents etre majorité
également là en l'occurrence ils étaient
interrogés sur une mesure qui les
concerne pas puisque cette mesure elle
ne concerne pas les résidents parisiens
ce n'est pas vrai parce que si vous êtes
résident parisien et que vous habitez
par exemple le 16e
arrondissement vous aurez un tarif qui
augmentera si vous allez dans un autre
quartier que le vôtre donc au final si
les
parisiture fait mais enfin au final les
paris est-ce que du coup il ne faut pas
aller plus loin et interdire tous les
SUV dans la capitale cette question
viendra peut-être aujourd'hui nous
n'aurions pas au vu de la loi le droit
d'interdire totalement l'accès ou la
possession d'un SUV à Paris ça ça ça ne
serait pas légal mais en tout cas de
tripler le stationnement pour tout le
monde en tout cas nous allons au maximum
de ce que la loi nous permet de de de
faire et je le redis quand on est
parisêch de taxer le ST r quand on est
parisien et qu'on habite le 16e on n'est
pas tout le temps en bas de chez soi il
arrive quand même que justement on
prenne sa voiture et qu'on aille dans
d'autres quartiers de Paris et à ce
moment-là on sera effectivement soumis à
cette augmentation du du tarif de
stationnement est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous dites aux familles qui viennent à
Paris dans des monospaces qui aussi du
coup sont concernés qui viennent de
banlieu qui viennent de province elles
pourront plus garer à Paris non mais je
je je je leur dis ce que les Parisiens
ont majoritairement dit hier par leur
votes ce sont des voitures qui sont
polluantes qui sont encombrantes et donc
vous avez tout à fait le droit de les
utiliser mais ce tarif FAM mais mais
mais ce tarif sera plus important vous
savez toutes les études montrent que
ceux qui utilisent à Paris des SUV sont
la plart du temps seul donc je veux bien
que certains nous expliquent que ce sont
des voitures populaires que ce sont des
voitures familiales je le redis la
grande majorité de ceux qui les
utilisent à Paris sont des hommes seuls
et donc en l'occurrence ça n'a rien à
faire avec la défense de la famille
Christophe Béchu hier sur RTL il disait
le référendum c'est un moyen pour
anidalgo de faire oublier ses voyages au
bout du monde qu'est-ce que vous
répondezou bah je je je pense que le
gouvernement lui serait bien inspiré
d'organiser le référendum sur les
retraites dont il a privé les Français
alors que des millions de gens
manifestai dans la rue pour demander que
cet exercice démocratique puisse avoir
lieu et donc en l'occurrence les
commentaires du Gouvernement sur ce
sujet me paraissent complètement à côté
de la plaque voilà et puis si Monsieur
Béchu a envie qu'on regarde son bilan
carbone il y a pas de problème Jacques
Yan brossa il y a il y avait aussi des
questions par arrondissement alors je
sais pas si ce genre de de référendum
plus locaux va se vont se
multiplier une a retenu mon mon
attention c'est la l'expérimentation
d'une caisse alimentaire scolaire
solidaire dans le 20e arrondissement je
sais pas si vous êtes intéressé c'est
assez innovant j'aurais voulu que vous
nous en parliez c'est une une
proposition qui a été validée entre
guillemets à à plus de 80 % je crois des
votants c'est vrai je je je je je l'ai
vu ça correspond par ailleurs à une
préoccupation que je partage pleinement
qui est la question de l'accès à une
alimentation de de qualité et je me
réjouis de ce vote dans dans le 20e bon
Paris est par ailleurs une ville qui
depuis longtemps se base sur cette
question de l'alimentation vous savez
que par exemple dans nos cantines
scolaires le tarif le plus bas il est à
13 centimes d'euros précisément parce
que nous ne voulons pas que des gamins
de milieu modeste soi privés d'une
alimentation de qualité mais cette
question de l'alimentation c'est
effectivement une une grande question et
d'ailleurs les agriculteurs l'ont posé à
leur manière par leur
mouvement merci beaucoup merci merci
merci à vous Jacques Paquier la nouvelle
cartographie des quartiers prioritaire
vu par les mares c'est à la Une du
journal du Grand Paris cette semaine
merci beaucoup merci Jacques d'avoir été
avec nous un mot sur une autre actualité
qui concerne Paris c'est la démission du
recteur de Paris qu'on a appris vendredi
qui avait notamment fait de la mixité
sociale un cheval de bataille est-ce que
vous regrettez son départ en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que son départ est
révélateur de quelque chose il est
révélateur de la crise suscité par
Amélie oua casterra qui est une ministre
qui afflige tout le monde et en premier
lieu les personnels de l'Éducation
nationale des enseignants jusque
jusqu'au recteur c'est quand même assez
fort de réussir à unir tout tout le
monde contre soi quand on est ministre
depuis quelques semaines d'ailleurs la
question se posera quand même de savoir
si cette ministre peut continuer à
exercer son mandat dans ces conditions
dès les prochaines heures puisque la
suite du rmanement est attendue pour
vous elle doit quitter l'éducation le
gouvernement ou justeéducation nation
considère que que cette ministre en tout
cas ne doit pas s'occuper de l'éducation
nationale et que aucun enseignant de ce
pays aucun parent d'élèves ne mérite
d'avoir une telle ministre à la tête du
du ministère de l'Éducation nationale
autre sujet qui concerne Paris Emmanuel
Macron a confirmé qu'il souhaitait le
changement du mode de scrutin pour les
prochaines municipales à Paris
lyonmseille où actuellement c'est des
maires d'arrondissement qui sont élus et
qui choisissent le maire de la ville là
ils souhaitent un suffrage direct vous
approuverez vous ce mode de changement
bah d'abord il m parce que en
l'occurrence personne n'élira son maire
au suffrage universel direct ça n'existe
nulle part dans dans aucune des communes
de France on n'élit pas son maire
directement on é liste c'est le conseil
municipal qui vote pour c'est le conseil
municipal qui vote pour le maire ce qui
fait d'ailleur qu'on peut changer de mer
sans aller devant les électeurs tout le
monde le sait donc à partir de là tout
repose sur un mensonge et en réalité ce
qu'ils veulent c'est organiser un
tripatouillage électoral qui vise à
maximiser leurs chances pour gagner les
prochaines élections municipales ils
n'ont juste pas compris une chose c'est
que une élection municipal ça ne se
gagne pas dans le bureau du président de
la République avec une calculette ça se
gagne devant les Parisiens puisque en
l'occurrence ça concerne Paris et pour
gagner il faut avoir un projet
convaincant et un bon candidat ou une
bonne candidate pour pour l'instant ils
n'ont ni l'un ni l'autre donc vous ne
voterez pas pour ce mode de non je ne
voterai pas pour ce changement de mode
detin c'est par ailleurs une manière de
délégitimer le suffrage universel
puisque en l'occurrence la maire de
Paris les maires d'arrondissement ont
été élus à l'issue d'un vote et ça se
respecte et en réalité tout cela est
fait pour les délégitimer je trouve ça
assez honteux est-ce que c'est surtout
que ça mettrait anidalgo en danger pas
du tout vous savez la dernière fois nous
étions majoritaires en voie et en
arrondissement et en l'occurrence si euh
euh il y avait eu un mode de scrutin
différent nous aurions gagné aussi donc
ils peuvent changer le mode de scrutin
autant qu'ils veulent la seule chose qui
leur permettrait de gagner c'est s'il
pouvait nommer le maire ben ils peuvent
pas nommer le maire c'est pas un préfet
et donc à partir de là ils perdront
comme ils ont toujours perdu elle doit
se représenter à nidalgo pour vous en
2027 c'est à elle euh évidemment d'en
décider euh et la décision lui lui
revient je crois que elle elle le dira
mais après après les Jeux Olympiques ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'elle nous a conduit
deux fois à la victoire et vous parliez
de la macronie je me souviens monsieur
Gau madame Buzin tous ces gens ont été
battus nous nous avons gagné donc elle
renonce pas à un prochain mandat est-ce
que ça crée pas des tensions au sien de
l'équipe municipale notamment entre elle
et Emmanuel Grégoire son premier adjoint
potentiel successeur moi je ne vois pas
de tension je vois surtout une équipe
qui est au travail une mère qui est à
100 % dans son mandat qui est très
concentré évidemment sur les GI mais on
le voit aussi sur d'autres dossiers on
parlait des des SUV tout à l'heure elle
est à fond et qui est quand même allé à
la présidentielle donc pendant un moment
le National l'INT ou mais en tout cas
elle elle est aujourd'hui à fond sur son
mandat et c'est très bien d'insi donc
elle elle ne dit pas non un mot sur les
européennes euh les sondages donne votre
candidat à Léon des Fontaine il donne à
peu près les mêmes scores que vous en
2019 non non un peu plus quand même vous
savez candidat je bien
placé quel est l'intérêt en tout cas
moins de 5 % quel est l'intérêt de faire
une liste du Parti communiste bah pour
défendre nos conviction il a d'ailleurs
des Sondag il a des sondages qui le
donnent à 5 un sondage qui l' récemment
donné à 5 ma conviction c'est après vous
aussi les sondages vous donnez très haut
hein euh enfin vous donnez vous donnez
haut pour les européennes plus haut en
tout cas que le score que ce que vous AZ
fa en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il fait une bonne campagne Léon des
Fontaines est un formidable candidat et
surtout nous avons un projet qui est
clair qui est comment la France peut
retrouver sa souveraineté comment on
peut faire en sorte de se dégager de ces
contraintes de l'Union européenne qui
nous poussent à appliquer des politiques
libérales dans tous les domaines on le
voit dans le secteur de l'énergie
l'Union européenne nous a contraint à
tout mettre en concurrence alors que
nous avions un service public EDF GDF
qui fonctionnait bien et qui disposait
d'un monopole je pense qu'il est temps
que la France retrouve une souveraineté
dans le domaine économique et social
c'est ce que nous défendons avec Léon
des fontaines c'est mon candidat et je
me battrai ardemment pour qu'il fasse
les 5 % et pour que nous retrouvions
notre place au Parlement européen merci
y Bross merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité pendant cette première demiure